so I was just thinking that maybe we
could have a dance off here
[Applause]
four more to go more let's talk about it
like hi nice to meet you did you make
this phone call out yet
three million subscribers on YouTube
[Applause]
it's like a massive Harry Potter store
in New York now and I judge me like walk
past there and I have to not be here
very quickly I have to run before
somebody sees me in Wicked once I had
black tights opaque black tights on
underneath the big gown I've peed in
them and the taste just sapped it all up
and then it went back out Commando and I
sang Defying Gravity you know you try
singing for like three weeks straight
while staring at Will Ferrell I would
hit a note and he'd look at me and go
I don't lie to my children I I totally
lie to my children
I totally I'm outside I'm like oh
Disneyland's closed today I love you so
much we attend game nights forever right
I never get invited wait is that because
that's really true yeah because I'm not
a big enough celebrity is what I think
no doubt comes on the radio or when you
come on the radio and I'm driving it is
dangerous because I get so into your
impression
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's very fun to work with he was on
Reba when I did her show I know you
worked with him yeah I did you never
told me that well I don't tell you
everything
[Laughter]
what is black Adam's favorite Dwayne
Johnson movie I made a movie one time
with my wife
no never mind sorry
I don't think when you're that lean it's
actually dangerous
new public service announcements not
good for you this is why it don't work
out anybody in the comments give us a
jingle to write always need more cowbell
[Music]
was it 15 seconds it might have been
something like that we have Matthew
McConaughey on and the first thing I
said to him is do you have any idea who
I am and he was like oh my God
can you wear
Jason play a song she'll love
[Music]
[Applause]
her voice was a gift she was born with
and I believe it's unmatched by anyone
alive but it's her authenticity and her
heart that has captured the soul of
America in the world these past 20 years
today Hollywood honors Kelly Clarkson
with the
2733rd star on the Hollywood Walk of
faith in the category of recording
oh my gosh
so H Miller is going to tell you their
story
devastating what has happened but to
also like see these murals and
experience what they were like living
like it's life and
and that's how you want to
well that's how I would what
my child a lot of people are addicted to
like Pharmaceuticals in general like
that's an important thing that people do
not talk about this album without a
doubt saved my life I thought that it
was really cool that you were so open
about I mean having lupus about bipolar
disorder it wasn't easy and I think
that's why I wanted the documentary to
feel really personal one person tweeted
so happy to see dark-skinned Indian
women playing female leads in Bridgeton
season two what it's doing has been so
amazing yeah it's so amazing and when we
got to go I don't know why I'm getting
Solutions but when we went to the
British and experience the other night
and seeing people of all shapes sizes
colors there celebrating the joy that
this show has brought them yeah it was
it like really touched your hair but
it's so beautiful
and it says Papa I love you
why did you do that I think
in the face
2555 please
I think I can speak to parents Maybe
and that is to say that the child who
comes out to you is the same child they
were
five minutes ago before you knew this
there are so many marginalized people
that it's just it's easier to walk by
and be like oh I couldn't do anything to
help that person I mean but that one
person's life could be drastically
impacted by one act of kindness and so
we're all about changing the narrative
and bringing light to stories that are
so
beautiful our mom died of brain cancer
83 days ago
one one child from her class RSVP every
inbox on every social media platform was
just full of people asking how can we
help well we want you to be able to
create even more awesome memories so we
are sending you on a family vacation to
enjoy a four night five-day luxury
included vacation to beaches Turks and
Caicos it's incredible
maybe you're the one with a thousand
dollars
oh I don't know buy stuff for my dogs
because I love them and they deserve it
yeah this is from Kelly is this from
Santa herself wow oh I'm in little L
this is a personalized note from Kelly
she can't wait to hang here's the secret
I actually already have this one because
that's how in tune we are in terms of
taste I want to see what creepy Chloe
does Kelly
[Applause]
she's like I'm so exciting about it I'm
just gonna strings good job of mine
every day
wait that's not you though yeah wait
what yeah my child will say mommy you
know he smokes weed
oh please tell me your response is so
does Mommy
[Laughter]
what a message
when we did the Academy of Country Music
Award you absolutely killed I'd like to
thank my mom for always being there for
me and for the best coach in the world
Michael
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]